today the Samsung Galaxy is a flip is
released and we are going to a Samsung
experience store this is not sponsored
by the way it feels like it because I'm
I'm speaking very sponsoring but I'm
going to purchase the phone put our
friend John actually I already got the
phone so I'm basically gonna be paying
him for the phone and then I'm going to
take the phone from him and I'm gonna
unbox it at the mall Jenna we're at the
mall we're at the mall and they go see
the Samsung experience Samsung Experian
it right means a LenDale first I'm
excited because they have the mirror
purple one and it looks so pretty at the
Sampson event that we went to there's
also a Lego store here that's why I come
to Glendale I come to Glendale to go to
the dentist and go to the Lego store no
it's here trust me
it's here trust
it's here
that's actually a really great question
trust me it's here I think it's out son
oh my god is it really you think it's on
the other side
deine mess up it's not here at all
oh hey do you want to be on Amazing Race
absolutely not it would get made fun of
should we get back in the car it's not
that far okay I thought that part we
lost well it's like right over there
right let's walk you see the walk around
right here right you're right you're
right
[Music]
one-hour free parking
two hours free parking Whitaker got a
car wash I have really messed up
[Music]
okay the deals going to one purple and
one black every strike two phones in
that's incredible
[Music]
yo how am I gonna pay you you can walk
around say you want then no like this
telegram do thing I can write you a
check
[Applause]
we are here gonna unbox we are cave what
gonna unbox your iam box so we unbox for
John's Channel and now he was kind
enough to reserved me a bird
thank you so much I appreciate it my
pleasure by the time I got home they
were all already reserved yeah
hit the gold mine on Best Buy this is a
mere purple I don't have a knife I don't
want to break their stylus you need help
are you weak I almost always have a nice
butt since I was travelling yeah we made
it all the way to Glendale today yeah I
mean if you want to use it let me know
you know um since I feel good at my my
black purchase but the purple is nice
[Music]
yes pink today because I don't really
own a lot of pink this was beautiful
when using a wireless charger fold the
device and place the center of the
devices back on the center of the
wireless charger that's actually that's
good information information we've got
some care instructions on the front it
says don't press the screen on the front
camera lens with a hard sharp object
weird I was planning on doing just that
when bolding videos do not place any
objects such as cards coins or keys on
the screen
hold up that's it would've been a good
thing come on Olli my credit card in
there not waterproof or dust resistant
yes no I'd be ready don't attach any
adhesives or films or stickers on the
main screen your device also contains
magnets so keep a safe distance between
your device and objects that may be
affected by magnets woody somebody has a
pacemaker yeah if you have an
implantable medical device consult your
physician before use oh my goodness this
is very solid construction I probably
should yeah you should I'm helping this
is incredible this color is so beautiful
he's like it's beautiful I was crushed
absolutely just heartbroken when I found
out that the only pink color very it was
in the s20 and not the s20 ultra like I
think s20 ultra people who want the
paper yeah but now yours wholesome flips
yeah touch it yeah don't touch it
it smudges compare your enjoy I'm so
happy
oh my gosh it's like high school and
everyone has the flip phone and I don't
my loser but you got a phone in high
school did you have a cluttered high
school college we're a little bit older
so young Jenna
oh here it is it's so pretty
USBC is this does this have expandable
storage I don't think yeah okay so no
expandable storage by 28 think it was
256 everything but the problem is I love
having we're gonna see hard in my
beliefs in phones because I feel like
transferring stuff as a Mac user
sometimes can be a little bit difficult
but I've been using the link share let
me use that it's great it's really handy
you also get 200,000 folds but what
we're wondering is what constitutes the
fold is this a fold 1/2 or was that one
that's one I think what's so it's
folding it's unfolding more than folding
saying oh I guess that is just one
unfold yeah because you're not yeah I
think that's one I think that's what do
you guys think is the question so gonna
have to to 12 megapixel cameras on the
back yeah is a 10 megapixels
he said it's wide and ultra light on the
back and then it's 10 on the front
actually the same camera system
I like it the hinge is also very it's
pretty stiff too so you know if you do
want to get some cool time-lapse is I
would be careful when you set it down
though if you don't send it on to me
like rocks or something or any of the
things that could be there that magnets
yes make sure no pacemakers so
everyone's question I feel like is what
happens if you slam it like when you're
mad you want to hear it cancel your post
mates order man what oh okay so this is
my this is how I'm flipping I go like
this
hello it's a nice may seem very proud
about the hinge yeah there's like a
little like brush bristles in there to
protect from particles getting into the
hinge but since it isn't dust resistant
I mean what does that actually mean and
the purple just hang out there right you
get a lot of them then you push your way
up we need what's inside to tell us
what's inside the hinge we do so my legs
are asleep again Mike that's why I'm
sitting like this I can't go many yeah I
think we're done unboxing now so I'm
gonna continue on to whatever else you
is that we're gonna do today we're gonna
go the Cheesecake Factory is I wrote
spaghetti
[Music]
I bet contact yes ah covergirl clean
beautiful hinge on this is broken
[Music]
oh my gosh it is so shop we're
gonna walk out okay ready
[Music]
I'm making a video Jenna do something
perform Wow look at that
am I in the frame look good your arm is
long I think I have the wide angle on
yeah do me to make it finer sure ready
how does the screen look does it look
good yeah can you see the grease dad on
I don't see it from the side I see it oh
no I'm getting a phone call or my other
phone
I think the trolleys about to take off
we should probably move the trolleys
gonna hit us
choo-choo we're gonna take a selfie on
the front facing you you DoubleTap can
you see it you'll see we get the trolley
in the back we can't exert
[Music]
yeah this is reporting out on the
front-facing camera doing a little test
here hi Jenna
we're gonna go to the Cheesecake Factory
I'm gonna go home but I'm really hungry
and I don't think that I can wait that
long in traffic before we eat food that
live music I don't think it's live like
it's like it's before it
[Music]
around around yeah
gosh my patience today oh there's a food
option although you looking like a snack
[Music]
the galaxy is a flip
six point seven inch AMOLED display this
top little cover is a 1.1 inch AMOLED
display this can be used for
notifications and also taking
front-facing selfies the front-facing
selfie camera is 10 megapixels the rear
cameras there's 2 if there's a 12
megapixel ultra-wide camera on a 12
megapixel wide-angle camera it shoots up
to 4k UHD at 60 frames a second it does
have wireless and fast charging it also
has wireless power chair it's equipped
with 8 gigs of RAM 256 gigs of internal
storage the power button also acts as a
fingerprint sensor all with the 2.9 5
gigahertz 64-bit octa-core processor and
it'll only cost you about $1,400 but oh
my god
that was my biggest fear as I was going
to flip it and I was going to
accidentally throw it good thing I'm in
a confined space let's try that again
all for just $1400 hello
the flip is satisfying closes tyler
doesn't think the clothes are satisfying
it's it's satisfying it's just for me
personally for him personally satisfying
as he wants it to kind of like auto
clothes which i get it but the reason
that I like this is because you can
basically make this stay however you
want like it's okay we'll see the closer
a little bit by itself yeah yeah so
we're back from our fun little afternoon
getting the samsung galaxy as you flip
so far this thing is pretty cool I
haven't really got a chance to fully use
it as an actual phone yet because I
haven't got a SIM card activated so that
is also in my to-do list before this
evening is over and I have until 9
o'clock but honestly first impressions
is this is cool
obviously I'm a huge Apple fan and I
of having my iPhone because it does what
I need it to do and it works in my Apple
ecosystem but I always have a second
device that is an Android phone so right
now this is gonna be it the question
that I'm asking myself am I going to
want to stick with this instead of
getting the Samsung Galaxy S 20 ultra
that's the real question because this
honestly is really it's pretty cool it
does feel a kind of novelty and it's
really funny because one year to walking
around with it and we were making your
video earlier a lot of people kept
stopping us on the street and we're
wondering what is that one of the things
that I like is apps will transform
depending upon if this phone is folded
or not folded so when we fold it you'll
notice that it moves itself up to the
top and you take a selfie so hold on a
second here
where do you focus it you me
oh we're taking another I can't wait to
try out some time lapses with this thing
it really does look like a compact like
there's no way around that it really
does you want to get the selfie
front-facing little camera here you know
if I want to take a picture I just press
it use the timer I know we open it
automatically will open that camera app
and there's that you're you suck yeah
you do that's a little it's a little
Graham gremlin desk I look forward to
testing this out more I'm just a little
worried because I've been flipping this
so much already that I'm probably at at
least 20,000 flips for the day that's
that's a lot I can't even realistic we
think of how many times I've opened and
closed it but again the question that we
were asking ourselves is what is a fold
is this a fold one or is this a fold one
1/2 or one leave us your comments below
thank you guys for watching be sure to
subscribe and like this video if you
enjoyed it I'll be doing some further
testing with this make sure you go check
out my sister's chance she made a little
vlog as well from our day so go check
that out she also has a few other videos
talking about some of the new Samsung
phones and of course she has lots of
other fun videos as well so I will see
you guys in my next video I'm gonna be
traveling here very shortly so I'll be
taking this with me and filming some
videos with it so let me know if there's
anything you would like to see it's
dreamy I'll see you guys in my next
video
[Music]